barcelona vivió una noche de
enfrentamientos contra el 'toque de
queda' cientos de personas salieron a la
calle a denunciar que las medidas contra
el virus atentan contra sus libertades y
que se están arruinando no nos pueden
quitar nuestros derechos básicos no nos
pueden decir que nos encierran en
nuestra casa ya lo han hecho una vez por
15 días y estuvimos 4 meses no lo veo ni
lógico ni ilícito ni que tenga nada que
ver con un virus pero la protesta en la
ciudad catalana no es un hecho aislado
durante la última semana se han
registrado violentos enfrentamientos en
ciudades como turín o parís un síntoma
de que en europa muchos rechazan volver
a cerrar todo por miedo a las
consecuencias los datos económicos
durante el anterior confinamiento fueron
devastadores en españa el pib cayó un 18
5 por ciento en italia un 12 8% y en
francia un 10 por ciento algo que podría
empeorar con otro cierre sectores como
el del entretenimiento llevan meses sin
poder operar de forma normal y el cierre
de cines y teatros en italia ha hecho
que los artistas saliesen a protestar en
roma' aunque de una forma mucho más
pacífica
en estos meses
se ha organizado en términos de
distanciamiento social de respetar
protocolos y hemos gastado dinero para
hacer esto pero habitualmente elaborador
en continuar hay que permitir que gente
trabaje incluso con las desventajas de
los protocolos y gastos para
recuperarnos y volver a empezar
necesitamos que nos vean y seguir
trabajando y hacer bici y continuaron a
laborar en europa se adentra en el
invierno con una segunda ola que
registra récords de contagios y que está
obligando a todos los gobiernos a tomar
medidas cada vez más restrictivas aunque
parece que el confinamiento total es
casi inevitable